we've been testing and using the M2 Pro
MacBook Pros for three months now and in
that time we have found a lot of very
unique things about these new updated
machines that most people don't talk
about so in this video I wanted to give
you guys an updated review with all of
the info and findings from both regular
usage to some more hardcore tasks and
talk about how the M2 Pro compares to
the M1 Pro machines that you can get for
as low as fourteen hundred dollars
refurbished on Amazon for the 14 inch
and fifteen hundred dollars for the 16
inch which is a thousand dollars less
than getting the M2 Pro now those links
are in the video description if you guys
want to check them out but that's a
killer deal so is it worth spending the
extra money and with that how do the M2
Pro Max compare with the best Windows
laptops now we just found out the
Apple's Max sales have plummeted by 40
percent which is absolutely terrible and
there is a reason for that now when we
were first expecting these M2 Pro and
Max machines most people thought that
they are going to be three nanometer
base because the producer of the chips
for Apple started to make those chips
already but as we got closer to Apple's
fall events this machine did not show up
in fact it was the first time in 21
years the Apple did not have a fall Mac
event so because of that we figured that
we are getting three nanometer they just
needed some more time or maybe even four
nanometer because that is what the
competition has started to put out and
they put a big marketing push behind
that but at the end of the day when
Apple finally released these it turns
out that they are still based on the
same old technology you just overclocked
causing it to use more battery and have
higher temperatures and we'll talk about
that in just a bit but that caused a lot
of people to be quite negative about the
machines and because of that it also
does not help with sales now with that
said in your day-to-day life you don't
notice a lot of that stuff and for
people that don't care about those specs
if you're buying this machine I want to
talk about what your user experience
will be like before comparing it to the
M1 and to Windows Alternatives now this
redesigned MacBook is an amazing machine
we have all of the ports including HDMI
we have magsafe and with the updated one
we have color matching cables we have a
larger display that has mini LED and if
you've never experienced this update
that display gets up to 1600 nits and it
makes HDR content look fantastic both
from movies and then even photos that
have high dynamic range like from your
iPhone
um just the whole display is really nice
with that the webcam is fairly good and
the keyboard and trackpad are also
excellent pretty much the best that you
can get and if you're upgrading from an
older MacBook you will be shocked by the
speakers the 14 inch is great in the 16
inch is just a shockingly good even
though I've had this redesigned for a
few years now it still surprises me when
I turn on a movie or play a video how
good it sounds and with apple silicon
chips inside they absolutely destroyed
the old Intel models and they run
quieter as well which is really nice the
battery life has been upgraded if you're
wanting to buy one of these you have an
older Mac or Windows you are going to be
absolutely happy with the system but
then the question comes back in is it
worth getting the empty Pro over the M1
Pro and there's a lot of little
differences that most people do not talk
about so I'm going to cover that but
first if you would like to be a part of
the exciting tech industry but you don't
know where to start check out our
sponsor Full Sail University at Full
Sail you can learn all the aspects of
computer science artificial intelligence
mobile development user experience and
game development in addition to other
degrees offered on campus or online full
sales programs will allow you to gain
hands-on experience while learning at
the pace of the industry wholesale
University's computer science Bachelors
offers concentrations in artificial
intelligence and mobile development the
AI concentration guides students to
design develop and Implement their own
AI Solutions while the mobile Dev
concentration focuses on programming
languages for Android and Apple devices
if you like design the user experience
degree goes in depth on what factors
influence ux design such as factors like
psychology and perception visual design
and systems design
graduates have worked with companies
such as NASA Unity Google and epic games
to name a few to find out more about
these exciting programs and how to get
started click the first link in the
description below or just head straight
to fullsail.edu maxtech now the first
difference between the M1 Pro and M2 Pro
is the webcam and the actual Hardware is
the same but it's due to the image
signal processor which results in actual
footage looking quite a bit better but
unfortunately the speakers actually
sound worse because of Apple's tuning go
ahead and take a listen
[Music]
familiar with me
the high frequencies have actually been
tuned down and I do not prefer that now
I mentioned that the empty Pro chips use
more wattage or power and because of
that the system heats up more so but
what is interesting is that apple is
okay with that the whole system runs
hotter but in these last few months you
don't really notice that in terms of fan
speeds because they want it to stay
quiet now the thing that irked me and a
lot of other people is the fact that
Apple downgraded the ssds because it
cost them less money if you get the base
512 gigs the speed is pretty much half
that of the previous MacBook that you
could still buy being cheaper now that
really sucks and if you're transferring
large files that could definitely make a
difference but I will say day to day
with regular use you don't really notice
it like you do on on the base level M2
chips and to fix that you need to spend
at least 200 more for the one terabyte
just to get the speeds of that 1399
dollar M1 Pro refurbished model now as
far as performance that's where the M2
Chip should do a lot better right well
if you look at geekbench 6 it is clear
that you are getting some performance
and then taking a look at actual usage
for example photo editing you notice the
difference and that is because it uses
both a CPU and the GPU but other tasks
like video editing in real world use
it's not that big of a difference in
exporting well the speeds are the same
because the actual media engine has not
changed now in terms of gaming
performance not a lot of people game but
the graphics it has improved and certain
bottlenecks have been removed because of
the tlb cache memory that limit has been
greatly improved but you only know
notice that fact if your system is maxed
out or if you're doing something that
maxes out the graphics which a lot of
times that does not happen but in terms
of battery life this is where it gets
very interesting now in terms of mixed
use you can get better battery life
because of the efficiency cores that are
in the Mt Pro chip we have four of them
instead of two they're a lot more
powerful and if you're doing light tasks
you can actually get better battery life
but when you push the system hard it
does get worse now recently one video
that I put out showing you guys how to
get the best battery life on a Mac I did
more testing on using the low power mode
and using it for very light tasks like
for example surfing the web and emailing
in that the 16 inch M2 Pro can hit 24
hours of battery life which is
absolutely insane and your M1 pro model
will not be able to do that this is one
of the most impressive things about the
M2 Pro chips for example with the 14
inch in low power mode you actually get
basically the same performance as the M1
pro at full performance so yes you do
lose some performance but not very much
and as a plus the temperatures of the
system get lowered so much so that the
fan stays off while the M1 Pro would be
running so the issues with heat well
those are gone in low power mode and in
these last few months I was just able to
leave the low power mode on all the time
without really noticing any performance
loss so I think that is actually an even
more important part with the M2 Chip
than the actual performance gain that
you can leave it there get killer
battery life and get very very good
performance now I will say that that
won't matter to everybody because the M1
Pros already get killer battery life
much better than Intel systems so maybe
you won't mind plugging into charge
especially with a 50 charge in just 30
minutes but to me that is really awesome
to have a silent machine that has insane
battery life and with that the other
surprise that we found are the Wi-Fi
speeds I did a full in-depth video about
this because the M2 Pro machines can
support Wi-Fi 6E and that gives you much
better throughput but what Apple didn't
mention is the fact that regular Wi-Fi 6
has double the bandwidth and better
reception as well so just by updating
your laptop your speeds could be greatly
improved so if that's something that
matters to you if you have bad reception
or multiple floors that could be a
reason to spend the extra money on the
M2 Pro so with that said before I cover
the Windows laptop side of it is it
worth spending that extra money well
well personally even though we have
these updates I think that if you're
looking between a 1399 refurbished M1
Pro and two thousand dollars for a 14
inch model or 2500 well that is a really
hard sell and I think personally I would
not do that now if you're somebody that
can grab one of these killer deals and I
do think they will keep coming up 250
bucks off of the Mt Pro 14 inch and the
discounts on the 16 inch well in that
case I would spend the extra 350 bucks
for longevity and the other benefits so
that is a price Gap that could be worth
it now with that said how does the M2
Pro compare it to one of the best
Windows laptops well we did a full
in-depth video on this and that is where
the MacBook really shine having larger
batteries better performance especially
if you're using it as a laptop unplugged
the Samsung with the latest Intel
machine slow down dramatically in terms
of the CPU performance in terms of
graphics performance almost half and
also for real world productivity like
video editing the Slowdown is Extreme
and then with that the battery life
difference is really massive as well for
example Tom's guide did a battery life
test on this machine they said it's
great but the 16-inch MacBook lasted
almost 19 hours in their test compared
to 10 hours with 60 hertz screen and
then 8 hours for the 120 hertz that you
want to have enabled that is literally
twice as good and I presume that this is
without the low power mode with that the
speakers are better the display is
better I mean you really cannot compete
with these new MacBooks even though the
actual prices are the same so if you're
a chaos Mac OS the Mt Pro MacBooks are
absolutely absolutely phenomenal in
every single way and really the only
major issue with them is that you could
still buy the M1 Pro machines for a
killer discount so there you guys go
that is my update it's an amazing
machine but because you can buy the
element Pro for such a good price a
thousand bucks off on the 16 inch it
really makes it a hard sell you guys let
me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below once again we have
all the links down there to those great
deals click that Circle button to
subscribe and I will see you in the next
one
[Music]
foreign